ready two one i don't know i'm counting
and
let's go
[Music]
yo what's up jake what's going on
welcome back to the corridor digital
podcast we have a very
special guest today mr
nick laurent i was gonna say that
i was going to say someone else's name
guys
see mike is in the house see mike is in
the house along with
ren and nick and myself carmichael good
to see you man how have you been
i've been great now yeah i've been great
well wait what was that little
hesitation uh today's a bad day
oh no what but you're here this is the
up oh this is up okay
okay so yeah i had a kind of a rough day
too it wasn't the best day but
i mean listen my rough days aren't that
bad i'm not complaining but
right you know like when you're when
you're completely i'm trying to
understand this new process i'm
completely overwhelmed by it
and you're at that point of complete
being completely overwhelmed
and you just have to step back and go
i'm going to understand this but jake
today
is not going to understand this that's a
future jake thing yeah it's going to be
jake sometime in the future
who's going to look back on this i i
learned about
past me and future me method of thinking
a long time ago and when i used to live
in florida
one day i was just starving i had no
money for groceries
i was just sitting there i'm like oh
gosh and
the couch that i'm sitting on is
underneath my college bunk bed
and i just grabbed it like an idiot and
i was just like i just want to shake
this
bed and my finger touched something
and i pulled out 100 bill and then
instantly by looking at the hundred
dollar bill i remember
putting it there in case of emergencies
and i was like thank you past me
that's amazing now it's like but what if
he moved and totally forgot you put it
there it's like the next roommate coming
in
i mean past me is a complex character
you know
sometimes he he gives sometimes he takes
[Laughter]
that is the truth man i'm having a
rougher than average day
for me you should talk to the doctor uh
so i i said it in a sentence on discord
before
hopping in jake did you read that
sentence yeah okay one uh
friend do you have a habit of popping
out your shoulder no i do not
so okay all right i
i dislocated my shoulder earlier today
i'm so sorry
it was very painful i'll give you one
guess
how i did it you jumped over a table of
guns and landed on concrete
i'll give you two guesses on how i did
it plunging the toilet
i think i got it i'm not adrian
you you were on a one wheel
riding i was on a one wheel one wheel
on top of a tesla no i i i
fell off my one wheel and dislocated my
shoulder and
bruised my ribs jacked up my leg ruined
my vessy shoes
all because i didn't see what you
shouldn't have been doing so i want to
talk about that jake
no i wasn't yet
no no see i
i'm at a point now where i'm constantly
pushing my skills
as a one-wheeler so i'm always like
doing really sketchy stuff like kind of
like
stuff where i could get injured i have
never once been injured doing something
dangerous on a onewheel and i think it's
because i'm always a hundred percent
there and i want to get to that i have i
know i've hurt myself
we'll talk about that in here in a
minute carmichael's in any way the clip
yeah yeah yeah the only one exists so i
think it's because i'm always
100 present in the moment i'm constantly
like reading the ground around me every
time i've been injured on a onewheel
it's because
i was not paying enough attention and so
what killed me today
was a ghost bump and that is the name
that i have
for basically uh little bumps in the
road that
can ruin your day but are also kind of
hard to see
i call them ghost bumps because like
it's a little bump that isn't big enough
to cast a shadow so it's
it's literally like impossible to see um
unless you're like paying attention
right uh today was a little bit
different because i actually like
it wasn't quite a ghost bump i hit like
this slight incline
half curb style thing i just rode
straight into it
and it folded the board over like the
board literally just rolled sideways
because i was avoiding
this engine block sitting in the middle
of the sidewalk
i was like what is that it went down and
i saw
the board rolled out from under me i
went down my arm hit the ground and it
instantly just
shot my shoulder backwards and it popped
out i felt it pop out
and i hit the ground and i yelled out
and i realized i couldn't move my arm i
couldn't move my fingers
my fingers here i couldn't i was i'm
literally telling my hand
to move i'm trying to like squeeze my
hand nothing happens and i'm like okay
that really hurt
that really hurt and uh fortunately i
was with a few other people uh
uh jordan uh dean uh we're heading to
lunch peter was there
daniel was there he was riding his
bicycle dude um i
rolled over and that was when i popped
it back in i
felt it i heard it pop back into place
when i rolled over onto my arm
wow fortunately it wasn't worse than
that fortunately i guess it was in the
right position to be able to be put back
in
but i could i could feel it stretching i
mean i couldn't really feel much
uh it was mostly numb it's a scary
feeling not being able to move your
appendages
yeah it was really bizarre i'm like i
literally had like my hand is paralyzed
and the moment i popped it back in it
was searing pain
but like i could at least move my
fingers i still couldn't i didn't have
much movement
like i couldn't squeeze my hand or
anything but i can move it
that is the feeling that my body went
into
when we were in dubai my entire body wow
i did not expect this to go to the dubai
itself
michael got so high in dubai he couldn't
feel his hands
in my legs literally and i was trying to
tell
my feet to move they would not move
wow that's interesting and then my hands
were just
grabbing something to keep me standing
got to the clip
like laughing at the club i started
going into a tiny bit of shock
after that so like i was fine once my
shoulders popped back in i was able to
stand up
i had to sit back down because i got
very nauseous but i was like okay this
is weird
um but i was fine and we got i got back
on my onewheel and we continued going
they they broke off at bread lounge net
and i continued on to panda
and um i had to stop on the bridge
because i was shaking
so violently i was afraid of falling off
my one wheel because i was so shaky
i had to stop and just kind of like i
was nauseous i was shaky and that was
like yeah you're going into shock right
now i was like what
so i just like we took a moment i kind
of just like calm to myself and i was
like okay i'm good
daniel had some ibuprofen ready to give
me uh at the moment
but i refused it in the moment because i
hadn't eaten yet and i get sick whenever
i take ibuprofen or
any pill any yeah on an empty stomach so
i i waited until i ate and then i
took him up on that ibuprofen well i'm
happy you went to go see the doctor
dr pepper get that doctor's appointment
this is our health insurance here
you should go see a doctor after i'm
going to feel it i mean i'm i don't know
if i need to see a doctor per se but i
will try to see
maybe a uh like a physiotherapist i
should see a nurse
i think i think you got one waiting for
you yeah no dude that has come in the
play that has helped me so many times in
my life i'll come home and i'm just
bleeding everywhere
and jen is like i got you and she
literally wraps me up in bandages yeah
like a mummy yeah i get like expert
pro uh health care at home
heck yeah health care at home but yeah
so
uh healthcare i guess what i was saying
with the shock aspect is that when
you're in dubai and you're feeling that
i think that's a
mild form of shock like your body was
literally going into shock
and and it's like you literally can't
control your body sometimes like
when you guys played that that spider
prank on me years back remember that
i've been watching that clip a lot
lately such a good video
do you just like have like a little shot
in freud meditations where you just
watch
all the times we pranked ren at home
looking back at it
it's there's so many times where i
pranked you
in the kind of like a sibling kind of
way but there's also the subtle moments
where you prank me back
you know but like that spider thing like
the moment i realized that you had
placed a spider on my hand i didn't
understand the context of that
all i saw was that there's a spider on
my hand and next thing i know i'm
bouncing off of a wall
[Laughter]
like i just i ran i'm glad i hit the
wall i'm glad i hit the wall and not the
window because i don't know if i would
have just gone through the window
uh yeah it probably would have been fine
i mean
it would have been a loud noise yeah
that's fair but in
that video though like a solid like 10
or 15 minutes are
cut from the moment i like because i
like i walk into here and then 10
minutes later i walk into the studio
from the back
yeah and in the video it's just like out
of context like i'm like hey
what's up it was like yeah no big deal i
was just dealing with the shock
and and all the bodily responses of that
aka i was just crying
yeah it's it's funny that
looking back at the videos i went into
the comments section just to see like
have we triggered too many people by
this content
and like at the top of these uh threads
wren you're pinned
like explaining no it's okay it's okay
we did eventually have to stop the the
pranks though they got a little out of
hand they got out of hand
we kept on scaling them up but farting a
bell sound while running away was really
funny
farting a bell sound
i missed that reference remember the
remember the story of when we were
trying to do the bell candy crank on you
would you ring a bell and a piece of
candy would show up on your desk no i'm
aware
that was the thing that made this video
do you remember right now do you
remember that
so and uh
do you remember this five times you
followed us out to the hallway
and i had the bell in and every time i
stepped away from you the bell
almost like dinged and i had to run away
digging
he was like trying to hold the bell like
he just like crapped his pants like
all the way down the hallway but yeah so
so speaking of
like one wheel injuries i've had a few
crashes at this point every time it was
because
i wasn't paying enough attention to the
road uh and i
like i hit some sort of bump because of
me go down the first time that was legit
bad was right before my ted talk and i
got all
dinged up and that was on my phone the
other two times it was like literally i
just didn't see a
bump however i've gone down other times
uh similar to the way you have
so there's a moment in the video where i
build an electric bicycle
and i take it out for a spin no i think
i just built the bike and i was taking
it out for a spin
and you were following me after four
three rebuilds no no no because the
motor would
this is before i got any electronics put
on it i just assembled the bike
and i'm just writing it and you're
following me on the one wheel and i was
very impressed i was like man
don't worry but you got really good at
one wheeling i'm proud of you
look at you riding the one wheel like a
pro and like i've seen people be like
that moment was staged pro pro pro
and it was like that was so real i was
blown away i could not believe the time
i literally just said you're
pro on a one wheel and i just see your
panicked look like
huh like he felt the jinx wave hit him
like did the pyroclastic jinx flow just
hit
carmichael and he was just murdered by
it like
just hit me i'll never forget the look
of fear on your face like like a
betrayed dog or something
just like and why you do this as you're
going down like
i could you just your whole body was
going forward you're still just making
eye contact with me as you're falling
my whole thought process is dude not on
the camera
yeah that shot's so good though dude
like the camera pulls a full 360 and
then the battery is all
everything falls apart and goes in the
frame the freaking double-a batteries
i had to we can't we're not monetizing
that video anymore because
the hello darkness my old friend
really caught up to us it finally caught
up to us i forgot about that it did yeah
it's such an iconic moment of the
channel that i don't want to like
cut it out of the video or like i'll
leave it yeah
affect that sequence in any way
it's the same thing as playing hello
darkness when uh we were doing go-kart
you don't cut that out yeah sometimes it
just
you know it works perfectly my favorite
is to change what's perfect the frame
by frame where your head is here and
then your head is here
yeah one frame
yeah oh yeah some great moments of uh
injuries
but we can laugh about it now because no
one actually uh died no one died yeah
no one actually got serious let's be
grateful for that yeah yeah we got away
scot-free but
riding one wheel is dangerous man i
remember it is it is you got your one
wheel when
uh five years ago five years ago and
you'd always be riding it around and
like i was always terrified
right when we were getting neck deep
into uh like the first year i got it
right before we shot drone star wars
which would have been
around early yeah you got 2016. because
from star wars you took it out and
we were you were showing me i was like
what the [ __ ] is going on yeah
and i'm riding on it i'm like dude i'm
gonna break this i should get off
oh man i was terrified i tried it a
couple times and i like freaking flipped
in the wall
and like it was so scary i was like i'm
never going to ride that thing
now you have one of the most souped-up
yeah the v1s are a little sketchy
because they don't have any sort of
back and the motor is less powerful you
can overpower you can nose dive way
easier it's like a death trap dude
like you have to be so careful but now
you have one of the most souped-up one
wheels out of all of us here
i yeah i went pretty hard you have the
off-road tire you have the nice like
foot pads you have the cbxr battery
yeah did you put a little uh
like a two of diamonds card in there so
i haven't yet in the spokes
no i gotta do that that's my next thing
i need to chrome it out too
yeah i gotta get some chromies um no
yeah i got the the new battery that that
you recommended uh which
takes it what up to almost 30 miles of
arrangement of 30 miles yeah
it's a crazy ride if you ride like slow
and on flat ground you'll get a lot of
miles yeah and then christian and i were
commuting to uh work the other day and
his tire popped
and it was like well this might be a
good time to get a new tire christian
i was like well i kind of need a new
tire too because mine's turning into
chalk so i'm gonna well plus you guys
were both rocking the uh the stock
uh vegan tire which is my least favorite
tire by a
large margin i wrote stock though for
like two years like
i like rode the v1 and then i rode the
stock xr for like two years
so yeah it's been a while it's been a
long time coming but yeah it's like a
whole different board though
it is the vega tire complete with the
battery is like
and the new foot pads the the cush high
panel you got the burris tire
sorry why did you say that with the
battery and the kush high pads is like a
different different board yeah it really
is honestly like
you know i think the onewheel is an
amazing machine but upgrading to the
cbxr battery which is a process like you
have to like literally open up the
battery module after taking your entire
board apart it's surgery
and then you have to like carefully
unplug the things in the right order so
that you don't fry the battery
management chip
uh yeah it's like if you leave the
the balance wires plugged in when you
unplug the battery the balance wires
will literally fry the board so you have
to like make sure that you
unplug it correctly so i yeah i did that
installation to assure that it was
correct
but it it it doubles the range of the xr
one wheel
and in my opinion that's the biggest
impact you can make to the the one wheel
just increasing the range literally like
another board
that's crazy it's a holding board it
opens up so many new doors for like
potential rides you can go on
i spend most my time never worrying
about how much energy i have now and
it's like but also on top of that
this ride that i couldn't do before
because i wouldn't be able to make the
distance now i can
now you can get to the airport on time
yeah so now it's uh you
me jan and nico all have cbxr batteries
so
dude my dream is like eventually to do a
backpacking trip where we one wheel
like but for that we're gonna need a
charging solution in the woods so like
solar charging yep
and once we get to that point dude each
one of us will have to like carry like
this giant foldable like
uh solar panel thing that is just for us
because it's just barely large enough to
power
like one like one piece of it like and
and like the army how they all carry
part of a tent
and then they all like the platoon comes
together and they all build their tent
yeah totally it could be like that for a
one wheel and like yeah you ride for
like maybe like what two hours a day
charge up the rest of the day and then
chill i mean that's the things that like
in order to get enough charge on a one
wheel like you'd have to have a very
large solar panel sitting out for the
entirety of the day how large do you
think
how large pretty large really the size
of this couch
yeah dang it okay so we gotta wait like
three the size of this couch would be
enough to charge
a one wheel at the same rate as like a
wall charger yeah yeah
so the question is and they're all heavy
and not holdable yeah yeah
um
well this is a dream that might have to
be set aside it's something that we've
been
we've been talking i've wanted to do a
video where i basically fill the frame
of a onewheel with batteries so it's
just one
giant battery pack that is meant to
charge like two or three different one
wheels at the same time
but it's in the shape of the blade of
the one wheel so like the foot pads
minus the motor and big a big puck
basically yeah like yeah basically like
a skateboard yeah
guys and gals get ready to get your
learn on with today's sponsor
brilliant.org
brilliant is the best place for you to
learn fundamental concepts of math
science and computer science online they
also have an app which makes it really
easy to learn
on your phone the best thing about
brilliant is that they have interactive
experiences
which help you understand these concepts
and learn the underlying
principles to how these formulas are
applied to the concepts at hand which
allow you
to better understand the laws that shape
your world
one of my favorite courses that i
recently took was in cryptocurrency
that's right now
cryptocurrency let's just talk about
that for a second
is it as probable as just
shaking this eight ball and seeing what
result you get in my opinion
after i took the course on brilliant.org
perhaps it's not
that improbable it's a very interesting
field i'll tell you that much and i
learned a heck of a lot more about it
through the course that i took if you
guys are interested in learning more
things
about the world around you you can head
on over to brilliant.org
corridor cast to sign up for free the
first 200 people
to use the url will get 20 of an annual
membership
here let me tell you if you should do it
or not ready okay
you may rely on it all right see you
guys in the next episode brand deal
daniel
out so see mike when are you getting
your one wheel
you know i debated about getting it did
you um
yeah you talked with me about it i
i just was drawn to a motorbike
more my man uh
and i also like the fact that i don't
have to
pay registration
okay to be clear you got this the uh
super seven super 73
electric bicycle yeah one which is not a
motorbike
it is a it's a motorized
bike it is a motorized it's not a motor
we got rid of the rise out of that
sentence
uh but yeah i learned a lot more about
electric
uh bike laws in california which are
dope
what's your favorite bike law dude my
favorite bike law
is i mean i'm just like you know i want
to compare notes so tier one
being like the the birds and the
scooters
and the one wheels which are technically
supposed to be
on the sidewalk really yep
no technically the one wheel is supposed
to only be in the street i've gotten
yelled at so much for being on the
sidewalk like well
it does it doesn't go faster than
on average does it go faster than 50
miles an hour yes
it does yes then it would fall into tier
two which
has to be on the road because
you as the operator are allowed to
determine the safety of your
ride you're allowed to jump onto the
sidewalk whenever you feel fit
okay yeah i know it's like it's one of
those things that no one regulates no
one like is actually placing it right
and i've had two different ideas
there's so many different things i got
pulled over for it really
yeah i was like uh you're right for what
riding on the street or
riding on the sidewalk one i try not to
ride on the sidewalk because i'm
full throttle all the time it's also a
big honking bike too yeah yeah
i'll take them out um but at this
intersection
there was a semi truck there were two
dumb car drivers they're just like going
doing all their things
i was like no i get on the sidewalk and
i was just like i'm gonna go at least a
block down
until i get back on the road if
they follow me two more blocks while i'm
on the road and they pull me over and
they're
talking to me like is this an electric
bike is it a mo uh
motorcycle is an assistant pedal i'm
like it's a tier two
you can look up the california state uh
law if you want me to
open up my bag under my bike uh i can
pull out the paperwork
that uh points to the law
jake's tier three is you have to be on
the road at all time
that's basically above 25 miles an hour
but once you get past 40
you're considered a moped and then
above that is a motorcycle so like sam's
e-bike thing
is that even an e-bike i don't know
that's it that thing's like a truck
because he has bike pedals on
oh i see which is he specifically left
the bike pedals on so that it's not
classified as a
motorcycle so that's tears you're
allowed to have pedals if you want
tier three you can't have pedals
interesting
also with the one wheel it's slightly
odd there's been a lot of debate and i
haven't i haven't followed up on this in
a while because it's like
there's there's an argument that can be
made that the uh one wheel is what's
called an electrically assisted mobility
device
which puts it at the same classification
as an electric wheelchair
so anywhere that electric wheelchair can
go a onewheel can go
yep and a segway guys
in a segway but it's like but it comes
down to like the interpretation of
what it is is an electric is an
electrically assisted mobility device or
is an electrically
motorized board and that's a different
classification in california
basically runs it by speed
do all of these do all of these laws
even matter
no i ignore this one i i i break the law
i did
every second of my life i am a crime
ren red on a onewheel is
a crime actually your new riding now
nomaker should be
yeah i'm a crime the crime the crime
just
i'll take one crime please can i get
tots on the side
okay well hey um as much as i love
talking about electric vehicles we don't
get carmichael on the podcast very often
so
we should do we should do uh a little
bit of
there you go you wanna
how many miles have you put on your bike
three thousand three thousand miles dang
that's a lot of miles
for an oil change i've uh i've popped
that back tire
so many times it just pinches happen
yeah
we've had that same problem with our
studio studio 73 wow um super 73
the second time it popped uh someone
it happened so fast but i can remember
it as if i was watching
a shitty slow-mo scene was someone
popped their uh beer while they were
standing in the door when i was on the
road
and i can slightly remember the bottle
cap just
flying into the street and i and i go
and i'm driving and then suddenly
you witnessed the beer pop that left
your tongue that's crazy
and it literally is sticking out of my
tire oh my god how did their cap
get from the beer bottle to the street
they really they just
you know and you just kind of plunk it
over
oh they just did that they just did one
of those i mean that that's a
that is a intense plop yeah it was
whatever
i wasn't out in the road i was hugging
the shoulder a bit
which i don't do that much anymore i
take the road
your roadblocks i let them honk at me
it's the way it is in california it's
technically against the law to honk at a
bicyclist
do we need all these laws guys can't we
just dude
it's a 125 fine to perform a citizen's
arrest on someone next time they do that
i i'm good come on
i'd rather just wave at them i remember
one lady because i was
cause i can swerve everyone's coming to
a stop at a red light so i start
swerving between cards to get into the
front
and this old lady pulls up and goes i
hope you die
on that thing whoa and i was like [ __ ]
i hope you have a wonderful day ma'am
[Laughter]
she's just like that's the nicest dude
right there yeah
then she kept going and then i was like
why are you doing this
go away drive you're in a turning lane
i i don't know why like people can't
just like
give each other a little bit more slack
like yeah
just just like hey follow the law
let that person do them you know like
why
why do we always have to be like hey you
you can't ride that
there yeah you shouldn't be allowed
there ought to be a law
there is a law dude i mean we might be
like that when we're old though you know
there was the time where the dude in a
tundra truck rolled
over my foot ah
the pain came to me so quickly i'm so
fortunate
nothing broke in my foot
you got like wait wait wait yeah some
contacts here's
you put your foot down and he drove by
too close uh
no well yes and no so i'm at a red light
i'm in my lane
and the dude in an extra wide truck is
trying to get by
me to take a turn while i'm in the other
lane but i'm apparently too close to his
lane
and he starts honking his truck at me at
a red light like
what roll down the window and talk to me
you're literally like the distance is
nick and i
yeah like we're not that far like roll
down your window talk to me
and then he just uh starts moving
forward slowly and i just feel this
instant pain on my foot not realizing
what was happening
i look down and i just see a tire truck
a truck tire like just huge over my foot
and i just start screaming and yelling
and everyone just starts looking around
like what's going on
and i'm like get off my [ __ ] foot oh
my god like just
go to get out of here get your truck up
and then everyone else starts yelling at
me
i'm like why are you yelling at me he's
on my foot
and they're like get out of his way i
can't
and he rolls down the window to uh just
mock me or something like that i don't
remember i was too angry
man dude freaking la la road adventures
here yeah and now i'm just i take the
road
i just like i don't i'm not getting out
of anyone's way you take the high road i
take the hot
room so carmichael you uh you know we
haven't really seen much of you over the
last couple years
on the channel however you've been
really busy working with us for the last
several months
i've been busy so there's two shows that
you across the board
yeah oh yeah sure a lot of the audience
thinks that you've come back to make uh
crew cuts i i've i've heard a little
like whispers
yeah there's all these conspiracies that
pop up on reddit whenever like
freaking read it and they're conspiracy
it's crazy no one ever gets anything
right
and i've just yeah you just have to like
not engage yeah it's like well
it's just like speculation
never gets it right but like other
reddits sometimes get other things right
i'm just saying it's the speculation so
what you're saying is you're not helping
on crew cuts what are you helping on uh
well
jake needed some help mopping floors and
uh selling merch
thank you 2021.
15. you've always been there
i don't know how else we would keep the
studio nearly as dirty
without you you're welcome
uh no so i was soon
yeah it's like if you know how to swim
you should be closer to the river so
that way you're safer because you know
how to swim so you don't drown
i like fish uh okay
what was the question um okay so there
are two shows that we're putting out
there's functional filmmaking and son of
a dungeon and you're the you are the
show runner for both of those now uh
functional filmmaking is kind of
wrapping up the episodes are all mostly
done
wanna give a quick status update on the
progress of the whole show
three things there might be four but
three things still need to happen on
functional filmmaker
one clinton needs to finish some vfx
shots
two i gotta edit next video
three then it's gotta do and then nick's
gotta give me notes
to finish it dang okay
that's really that's holding it uh on a
thread there
yeah i'm uh i'm i'm very curious to see
how my episode is shaping up because hey
right now
the timeline says an hour 30 and i have
to cut it down
okay an hour 30 wow well an hour 30
that's how long your episode was
it was longer than that when we shot it
i was like i don't even remember filming
that because that was like i was so busy
you're shooting and doing corridor
you're doing corridor
was this last december yeah
you're shooting a feature film oh that's
right yeah
that's just like you need to write an
educational piece
the best the like the most frustrating
like
like kind thing that happened which was
like i kept fixing your script
because you're you kept writing in cut
to this or
shots ideas into a script like it was a
feature film script oh yeah i kept like
deleting it i'm like dude this is a
teleprompter script
that was weird that was my first time
ever having to read off a teleprompter
not to mention act natural slash like
fine like read and like actually
enunciate well yeah it's hard
that's the challenge with with uh with
you know reading
a prepared speech is that like you know
if you memorize it verbatim
there's a very good chance or if you're
reading off a teleprompter you can come
across as wooden
and uh if you just speak naturally and
just start kind of riffing on it you'll
seem way more natural but chances are
you won't hit all the points that you
need to make in the order you need to
make them and you'll get lost in some
type of weed somewhere
yeah dude you get a lot more like um uh
and uh
yeah yeah and then this like two takes
on the teleprompter like first take
let's get through it second take you got
it you're good let's
bust through another one a little bit
more relaxed
and what was it like a half hour per
take
once yeah which is really good because
if you think about all the times where
nick or i had to like
film ren talk about something science
related that was two hours of our lives
gone
it wasn't two hours it was one hour it
was an hour
you give us lots of material to work
with i mean you do
it's yeah it's it's what you want but
like yeah i mean there's definitely a
lot of
like repeated ideas because you got to
get everything out but with the
teleprompter it's like you have one
chance to say it
in your little section that you wrote
you know and you have to stick to it and
and the challenge with the teleprompter
is that there's two factors that you
don't really anticipate going into it
and that's the size of the text
and the speed of the scroll the speed
man and it's hard to get those
right so you know it's like and that
takes experience
because it's like it's different for
every person and so it's like you can't
just use
uh you know the format for one person
that works well for them and put it on
someone else
it might be too fast might be too slow i
i in my episode i love
like in the beginning you kept that bit
where i'm like doing this
because i kept get i think i was talking
too slow
and and the teleprompter speed was going
a little too fast and so like i would
miss up
i'd mess up what i'm saying and i just
kind of riff on it for like a moment and
actually do it very smoothly but then
like i'm also like i need to get back to
what i was saying in the teleprompter
thing and it's like
going up and i'm like okay now i'm
reading it from the top of the
teleprompter as opposed to the middle
and i'm like just trying to get through
it meanwhile it's like the text is
receding above i'm like
i failed i missed it also can you go
back you didn't go back
you didn't eat prior to that first
take i didn't no you were so exhausted
just
reading the first take every time when
we pause to rewind
you would you do the like the deflating
god what's going on like you're hangry
was coming
i don't think i was hangry but i was
definitely like weird oh yeah because it
was right after that that i went on that
whole freaking weird
chaotic energy bender remember when i
was like running around being all
chaotic and yeah
and crazy and then i jumped up on the
freaking banister and was like dangling
my feet 20 feet above the ground here
ren you you went on a chaotic energy
bender
usually it seeps out slowly throughout
the day usually you sweat it out
yeah it's it's it's very unusual but
yeah that
we i literally just stopped the show we
didn't even get through a
full first take with you i just stopped
and i was like go eat
okay i do remember that man just go eat
we'll start when you come back
i think i ate like a protein bar let's
or
yeah carmichael we've got
we got we're launching this show on
april we're launching the show
on april oh is that the day we're
launching that's the official launch
date
we're launching functional filmmaking
phase two of the website a i'm excited
for the reboot of the website green
light
options and soft soft hold on
april 8th just in case no
no no it's april 7th we can do this man
april 7th at 11 p.m how is it almost
even april 7th oh my god well carmichael
carmichael's make the world go around
wow
deadlines make the world go around
carmichael you know this i do
so you i do we gotta we gotta get this
over to nick so that he can give notes
on it like
yeah oh yeah i need to cut off my desk
by tomorrow
that comes into the like when we started
the episode like today was kind of on
the sucky end of the day was just like
for whatever reason i was recovering
from uh
the time shift and then small things
just kept eating away at my time and i
was trying to get to nick
and didn't get to touch your episode
today
i mean that's a lot and it really it'll
be a little technical
i can touch you tomorrow but it is bad
i was just like i i i don't want to do
what i normally do
which is i now stay up till midnight to
make up for the lack of time i was able
to dedicate to something bad
i i do that too yeah it's like if my if
the first half of my day wasn't
productive and i finally start falling
into like a productive trance like later
in the afternoon and evening i'll just
like i'll just keep pushing that yeah
just to compensate because i know this
about myself is that like in
the first half of the day i'm i'm rarely
super productive sometimes i am but like
i don't know i feel the opposite i'm
like always like so productive when i
first wake up in the morning dude you
make your coffee you get your nice
little coffee
if you go for a walk in the morning it
helps a lot oh dude yeah
but like it's like those first two hours
of the morning
are the best hours of the morning like
like that you're like working at your
desk that's why i love it for me
that's why i love it like yeah like some
mornings
i will wake up at 3 00 a.m like i just
finished a rem cycle
just perfectly and i woke up and i i'm
like i should
try to go back to sleep it's really late
but then my brain just
slowly realizes the wake and slowly
starts working and i'm like
i'm up oh yeah i'm starting my day
i'm gonna go to the bathroom make coffee
and start working
like a lot of the time when i'm working
late quote unquote like you know between
like seven and nine or ten it's not that
i'm
cranking and or crunching trying to like
put in extra time it's that sometimes i
find myself
in those hours being extra productive
being able to focus better
yeah and i'm like these moments are
precious so i just take advantage of
them when they when they do happen
so a lot of the time i actually prefer
working between like 7 and 10 p.m
because it's like they're more effective
hours for me
mm-hmm but uh all right so
but a troubling thing we'll get to
functional filmmaking is
yeah i love working from home
because one of the things i hate about
going from home to a workplace
is the commuting time yes it's a perfect
time to kind of
zen out a little bit and like process
some stuff
but my how my brain works is like i'm
i was already ready to start working and
now this buffer thing
is getting in the way of that and i have
to start that all up again once i get to
work
so when i'm at home i get up i'm having
coffee i go for a walk
if i'm reminded to go for a walk and
in it yeah so satisfying but then the
balance is
working from home starts becoming living
at work
yeah i that's where i struggle i mean we
all felt that this summer when we were
like hardcore working from home
but like yeah it is nice i do agree
sometimes the commute
can kind of stifle like for instance
like last wednesday or
it was like last wednesday or thursday i
took the morning from home because i was
editing the skillshare thing and i also
got to do some resolve tutorials which
was awesome by the way but like it was
like so productive for that two hours
because i wasn't at the office like
dealing with everything else
i didn't have to commute so i was like i
felt like i got a lot of work done that
i couldn't
shoot later but it was like okay like in
small bites like i can see how this
is nice but like when we were in summer
when we were all working from home it
was like super hot and just like
oh dude it was the worst man like it's
like all right i'm off work and you just
turn around your bed's there you're like
it looks so bad dude
i would like peel myself off with the
sweat off my seat and then like just
flop
on my bed i'm gonna dry off my sweat
with my head i had to move my desk away
from my bed and put it
i had to take over the dining room space
so that way i'm
like physically not in the same walled
area as my bed
but then we also have a murphy bed so i
just put away my bed too
of course you do so it's very efficient
for functional filmmaking how many
episodes are there are there five
episodes
five so five
clint's doing a vfx episode kind of
modeling and texturing
yeah his episode i watched half of his
episode
it's it's a it's very technical yeah um
sam's episode is about editing and kind
of like the philosophy behind editing
the philosophy of editing
with a little bit of a deep dive of just
watching him
go through a little bit of it gotcha
interesting so he actually sits down and
edits a piece in the episode
oh cool yeah that's nice yeah and then
uh nico talks about cameras and
and how to basically if i understand
this correctly correct me if i'm wrong
um i will
like he it's like you know how to
basically get the most out of any camera
regardless of what that camera is
correct and we went from the example of
from a red
to a phone to a gopro and then we we
talked about a dslr um
because everyone knows what a dslr looks
like it's it's the idea of how how to
approach what philosophies
you can take into approaching any camera
right in the in the i'm not going to say
what the biggest point is because you
got to watch the show for it
yeah um but yeah it like
all of it is technically technical
uh except yours well i
yeah so um but nick's episode next
episode i have more to say about that in
a week in a week okay but like but like
what's the premise of your episode was
it like
how to tell a story yeah how to make a
how to make a creature
it's kind of it's kind of just a bts
look at the crew channel and how we make
our story videos
yeah but yeah it's called how to make a
story out of anything which is which i
love that concept because it's like i
remember
nico did a whole freaking mic drop he
didn't actually drop a mic i dropped his
mic
in my head because it was so good uh he
was like i actually dropped the five
elements that make up a story
or to me to make a story out of anything
and it's like i forget i totally forget
the premise of it but it's like
basically like
uh character rhythm melody conflict
yeah it's like you get some conflict in
there you state what what's happening
and
like you do it and then you have like a
resolution and it's like you can do that
about like buying a pair of glasses
yeah something as simple as getting up
and going to go get coffee
there doesn't have to be a conflict
that's technically in the way
but the journey itself isn't the story i
got it you got your
goal
i think i know you got your your
obstacles
your stakes your
obstacle yeah sure uh
the solution here the character's
emotional journey
and the challenge that they face and the
conclusion
sure my personal breakdown is uh
aristotle which i i really like it's
plot character uh
dialogue music
rhythm and spectacle these are all just
ingredients to tell any story obviously
that doesn't touch upon
stakes or a character's agenda or
um resolution but it was more of a
technical
aspect and a technical approach that you
could kind of lay things out
yeah that's why i like dungeons and
dragons so much so
speaking of which perfect segue you're
welcome
i got two things i want to ask about i
want to ask about son of a dungeon
and i want to talk a little bit about
about that okay
and then i want to talk a little bit
more about you
specifically and some of the things that
you've learned
uh in your own journey so but before
that son of a dungeon what
what is that well it's a dungeon with a
sun in it
okay we're done with photography yeah
we're done
shooting all 14 terabytes
yeah um and then we have to shoot
probably like another terabyte of green
screen
what yeah so you guys have to and then
we're going to have another
reshoot i'm gonna just assume we're
gonna have one more terabyte
uh we're gonna have a total scan screen
oh there's gonna be so much post work
for this can we use ai to do it all or
something
i mean we're trying to get as many
automated tools into the workflow as
possible
we're using camtrak ar which is a phone
app for the iphone
that basically 3d tracks your scene in
real time and as it spits out the video
file it also spins out an after effects
file with a 3d camera already ready to
go
yep natalie's been experimenting with uh
getting that workflow up and running so
then from there you can just import that
into cinema 4d or blender or whatever
just go
and just render out your shot it's yeah
pretty good um
but yeah so like just to quickly kind of
recap the
the shooting schedule you know we shot
eight episodes
for seven and it was yeah so it was uh
it was four days of shooting each day
was basically broken into two blocks
uh one big block of us doing a thing and
then we'd break for lunch and then the
second big block of us kind of finishing
out the day
and we did two of those days in a week
because tech texas is over there and
jake
yep don't don't add it
so jake lives in texas so he had to fly
out to la for this shoot
and uh the idea is that like when he
flew back home he was we're going to all
take a week off from this kind of like
uh re um you know reassess and we're not
reassessing but we're here for the next
block of surely
that was it was more so for sam because
sam has more responsibilities than just
dming for two weeks sure yeah um
so then it came time for you to come
back and texas got hit by a
huge winter storm they're called snow
storms
all the planes got grounded they were
bad boys everything
shut down for a week basically because
we got hit with a giant
arctic snow storm and nothing's built
for that here so
not yet jake can be the entrepreneur
that starts at all
minnesota in texas you just had to bring
the minnesota weather down there
i was like the only one of my neighbors
who even had snow
clothes oh wow yeah
yeah i mean as in as in snow pants and
winter hats and and snow jackets
they're like jake what's that big puffy
shirt you're wearing yeah
t-shirt was not there i don't understand
it what is this cloth covering your
forearms and hands we're like making a
snowman
with the kids and my neighbors they're
like what's a snowman and their kids
came
outside and they don't have
winter gloves they're like why are your
cowboy boots so
thick they come
[Laughter]
so hey jake question about that i saw a
lot of things about texans saying that
the snow was fake because they were
trying to melt it
import democrats did you verify that
this was fake snow
or real snow jake sorry what
yeah so there's this whole thing about
the one i heard
so i have a two i have two of them
because a friend a friend of mine just
moved from texas here
uh one was videos of people using
lighters and candles to try to melt the
snow in their hands like a snow and
they're like it's not melting this is
fake
this is bill gates made the snow it's
gonna
be gates one verbatim are you sure it's
not meme
no there's too many but like
i just i found it funny because it makes
sense though because texans don't have a
lot of experience with snow
right yeah so that makes sense that they
wouldn't know
the actual physics but the other thing
it was melts into itself not down
but i mean the other the other one was
uh the democrats
bought the snow from china and put it in
texas
i mean uh if we're gonna buy perfectly
good snow
to be true actually yeah
we uh we talked to the democrats and
uh they told us we bought it and yeah
those dastardly dogs terrified
yourself i was just wondering
you are very well you're like the snow
expert down there now
yeah i was giving my neighbors tips and
advice
because they don't even have snow plows
here they don't have or salt people
don't even have snow shells like
the whole concept of getting hit with a
snow storm
is completely unconsidered
at every ass possible conceivable aspect
of society it's california southern
california is the exact same way
obviously yeah but yeah like it was like
like one of the things
everyone's terrified wow
yes so that was interesting and then a
week two weeks later
we i we finally got back on track with
that and uh
yeah because also during that whole time
we had to delay the the whole like
falcon trip flying out to texas due to a
number of reasons the climate being one
of them
but like was it changing yeah um
and and but yeah so it's like finally we
gotta we gotta sit back down
and continue doing the whole d d thing
and i i remember sitting down
at the very beginning of the first day
when we got back and i was like i forgot
how to play
yup i mean i picked it back up within
minutes but it was still like a little
bit of that kind of like
that's a that's a common thing when
playing d d is like oh
if you take too long between your game
sessions
you're like all right now i need to
learn how to durgan and dagon again well
it's
like it's almost like you kind of
compare it to
um like utilizing a software program
when you're in the middle of it you get
really good at understanding
you know and and there's almost like
inherent
techniques that you use to apply
creative techniques to whatever you're
making and half the time you're not even
thinking about them
your brain is just in it and then it
remembers and it repeats it
yeah and that's kind of like a lot of
the different steps in dnd
um there's there's all these things that
you are easily
able to do when you're like an hour into
a game
but when you step away and then you come
back you you have to
your brain has to switch into that mode
to understand all that stuff again
yeah because another part of that was
that like i had to remember how to play
my character
like what what how did what how would my
character react
in this situation mechanically and
role-play-wise yeah the role-playing
aspect of it because it's like
i realized halfway through the whole
thing i was like wait wasn't my
character supposed to be vegan
and i'm just like wasn't i supposed to
also be like
a pacifist and i'm like going around
like trying to chop people's heads off
and
you you fell into the the classic like
new player
murder hobo mode and i was like yep
there we go
classic murder hobo it was either going
to be he nails the role play perfectly
or he's going to become a murderer
everyone has that one friend who just
wants to murder
the tavern keeper like as soon as you
walk in
that i wasn't that bad
on me like he's warning you
no that was it was a really fun fun time
i'm i'm
really looking forward to seeing the
edited down uh versions of the whole
show
because it was a very fun campaign i
feel like uh the audience is
really going to enjoy the show it's a
very fun story it goes places none of us
expected
that's the beauty of d in actual play
and tabletop gaming it's just like
the only storytelling structures there
are
is the vague concept of arcs
that's the only thing that's ever going
to make it to the finish line
you're going to be like my character is
this so that means this might happen now
like you're going to plan that all out
and then someone's gonna roll a one
and then the only thing that matters is
one agenda or aspect about your
character that's going to make it to the
end
so who has your favorite arc out of this
session without giving away any spoilers
oh that's that's if i if i say which one
the audience will be looking for it yeah
that's true that's true you don't want
to lead him in
all right yeah well all i know is i
heard a lot of freaking screams
and like huge eruptions of laughter from
the other studio because you guys had it
all shut out yes you know yeah there's
lighting and like we kept it all closed
off yeah
a tough thing about the show that i
wasn't expecting
because i haven't been able to test
that many wireless lavs in one spot for
d d
but the the first couple days of
shooting
the lavs were struggling with their
connection
yeah which was weird we've never had
that problem before right um
on the second the second half of the uh
production
uh spencer brought this hardware that
acts as a receiver for all the loves
and the sound frequencies in a specific
range yeah it's like a spectrum analyzer
yeah uh that
would have that what that would have
that right yeah
spectrum analyzer you don't have a
spectrum analyzer yeah yeah i i i
[Laughter]
for those who don't know what that does
is you plug it into the laptop
and the laptop gets to see the the
the transmission signals happening in
the space
you know that moment in the matrix and
we got to like visualize and
like in matrix see all the code
happening yeah it's like you know that
moment in the matrix when neo like
finally like he sees the world but all
he sees is code
that's what's happening to the laptop
the laptop sees
radio waves and is like whoa this area
is empty
put your sound waves here and so we just
not with sound weights radio waves we
use that as a guide
to pick the right channels that reduce
uh interference and then we also learned
that whatever direction the antenna of
the receiver
is pointing you want the direction for
the transmitter to go
yes interesting so you don't want just
one laying down and they want
antennas that actually ruins the
connection even more
so we were strict about doing that and
then
we also put the sound recorder far far
far closer to the table
so there's less distance and less room
for error
and then which is why that recorder was
right there gotcha and then
i uh on day two like right away day two
i put
backup shotgun mics on the whole table
set up
with a whole nother recorder just
recording
super low like i think half the decibel
level that the lavs were at really yeah
because i knew you guys were also going
to yell
yeah like you guys started yelling and
it started like breaking
the laws that we were hearing on our end
i'm like it's fine i'll just cut to the
shop all i'll say is that i mean i feel
like the campaign
the best episodes i feel like are the
final like two or three episodes
yeah they're they're def they definitely
we almost got an
extra episode out of it yeah we did um
but like of course because there's
in the beginning you guys are trying to
like figure your stuff out
um and like where are we what do we do
and who are you
who am i on top of that uh
i think it's everyone not just you
everyone's first
time playing 5e i think d played a
couple times
um but like there was rule bending
between
3.5 and 5 going on which is a very
common thing in d d yeah um as long i
feel like as long as we're having fun
and we all agree that what we're doing
is acceptable or not
yeah it works at the table yeah exactly
i i am i'm slightly how do you play at
the end
that is how you play at the end of the
day that's how you play i'm slightly
concerned that like maybe the first one
or two episodes might be a little on the
awkward side because we're still trying
to like find our footing
and we get into it pretty smoothly
pretty quickly but at the same time it's
like
if i was to compare the first episode to
the last episode like
you know we all learned a lot about not
just uh like
you know the campaign but how to play
the campaign
yeah like these i'm just excited to see
it guys i honestly this is a great show
i think people are in for a treat now we
have months of post-production
i do know that is it months if we if
everyone green light
it's going to be months because every s
there is no like hey can we get a review
on this it's like no you can't i'm
trying to get i'm trying a single review
is a pass
that's how big the episode is i'm trying
to get you carmichael
spencer and natalie pretty much full
time on this
for three for three months
wow for how many episodes six eight
eight
wow okay eight like two hour long
episodes
two hour long as in the time that we
spent recording
it was longer than that for recording
and the
it was like two and a half three hours
per recording like node
d episodes was we'll just play a session
and we'll
cut down into a bunch of episodes we
don't know how many probably
this or that right this we have
a set number of episodes that we want to
hit
and we want and me personally i want to
balance
uh the node style of always
really being in at the table in the
minis
with you guys as players bantering
right i really want to balance that
because those are two stories that are
happening
uh so what's the reason why son of a
dungeon hasn't been touched yet
and i keep putting red tape around it uh
is
the first episode really needs a
director's pass
and then to bounce off sam and i we need
to like lock in the intention
right style you know like setting the
template making a format
exactly and then we can have as many
editors as possible
just chug through the first one or two
passes
and then i go in and do some creative
spraying
right okay i'm definitely looking
forward to the whole uh
recreation site we're gonna like reenact
some of some moments
and i don't know how often we're gonna
do this because it is gonna be post
heavy but like
uh we're gonna reenact moments as if
we're standing down
in the miniature castle or set or
whatever
and uh dressed up in our costumes
against a green screen
3d camera tracks it's going to be great
it's going to be great no one's oh
god yeah it's going to be like you are
there well
i got a big more question when you're
done before before that question
a big way that we're going to do that is
once we get to like let's say
80 edit lock on an episode
then it's it's about the the b-roll
uh pass where everyone involved is
putting down
markers on the timeline um like
this should be a scene a green screen
moment this needs to be green screen
moment this one this one
and we just go through that and then we
in and out
those scenes so we have video files
while we're
rolling on the green screen we can watch
the scene super quick
okay let's capture that okay that's the
plan
murphy and dobie probably will have
another
we've uh we've been conducting a
campaign to stifle dobie and
suffocate him so hopefully you will
you'll have a nice i love it
son of a dungeon is going to be the only
thing that's on premiere
yeah at corridor i mean i still am going
to edit everything in premiere
yeah that's how he's getting in oh
that's how he's doing it
well it's like i don't i'm not editing
videos frequently enough
to to go to resolve i have nothing
specifically against resolve but what i
do edit in premiere
is going to be very heavily tied to
after effects so it makes sense in my
situation
to maintain that that was that was the
argument that kept it in premiere
son of a dungeon i know it was yeah it's
a strong argument i mean that dynamic
link
it's very true very handy very
convenient because
we don't know we've gone through this on
the corridor projects that
uh we've shot or edited and resolved
it's like you have to actually kick out
and render out
files for the vfx and if it's a couple
frames too short guess
what you got to re-render the entire
thing
whereas in after effects it's like oh
because you're literally using the
source footage that you just sent over
from premiere you can just extend it
are you guys planning on uh
moving over to fusion a bit more no
probably not
well that will stifle your work yeah
well it's been a little bit i mean let
me rephrase
again i'm not the one to answer that
question i think dean is practicing a
little bit with fusion
only as far as to like be able to do
things that we would normally do
you know the the minimal amount of
compositing you do like in after effects
for a crew video
right yeah you can do it in fusion but
it's all node based so personally i
haven't delved into it
i uh i do miss the dynamic link for
things like you know some after effects
titles and stuff but
yeah i have to give it to davinci that's
a that's a pretty big thing to do is
have one
software active at the same time and you
can go from node
to timeline based it's uh
it's it's pretty sweet man i'm loving da
vinci because
that cuts page is really nice to help me
like lay out
i need i need to get i need to get the
little wheel thing so i can just scroll
through son of a dungeon footage at once
there's uh do you guys hear the rumbling
it's the right there's a rumbling up
there
there's a grumbling up this upstairs
and everyone's going to play some super
smash bros question carmichael
i mean i'm still down to keep talking
i'm just saying it's like it's because i
want to play super smash brothers
you know when this is over all that's
going to happen is i'm going to just go
back to my home
also can i just quickly point out jake
that that when you
won that game of super smash brothers
not not
set up by the way that was a real thing
that happened that's what i'm saying
it's like
but it'll be edited to look like it was
set up perfect
it was so perfect because it's like we
had this whole story line of you being
like ah you guys
can't aren't in your games and it's like
jake you don't get it you got
games are great and then you go and you
freaking win
in that shot of you just putting your
arms up and everyone like freaking out
like
it was so genuine and so real it's my
favorite moment because you're just like
oh that's what it's like
and people are like ah you staged that
and it's like no we didn't there's like
certain aspects of every single video
that are always staged
like the intro the outro so hard before
it's because i
i i ham up the character you're a hammer
so hard
before to some people don't some people
don't see that
somehow they're like they think that i'm
actually that guy i mean i'm that guy
like a little bit
but like not oh yeah not like yeah
staying in the video depends how much
money in every single video we're
playing characters not ourselves
and our our characters are based on
ourselves not me i'm always myself
anytime a camera is rolling yeah i mean
we can make a much larger philosophical
argument like i always take pride in
being able to be like what you see
on camera is basically me in real life
but at the same time i'm always this
a heightened version of that yeah i
don't know about you but i'm always
myself yeah it's a character
like the worst accent okay so carmichael
i'm giggling over here the question
everyone's dying to know
um in my room since your journey into
the unknown
started what what have you learned man
what's the
biggest thing you've learned and
what's been the hardest thing and the
best thing
when you say journey into the the
unknown you mean like leading corridor
yeah like since you've been to the uh
since we did the whole like carmichael
you know 29 mid-2019 yeah
it's coming up on two years now
well i just moved down the street dude
we still got the same taco stand wait
did you move down there it's a metaphor
oh but like did you did you move no are
you still in the same place
no i'm still in the same place i'm in
k-town okay yeah cool do you have any
takeaways for the audience
give me some wisdom they always ask and
i always see
videos that you are in people are always
asking
you for your yeah they want to know how
you're doing dude i mean
people want to know on the
example of today being a bad day like i
did a really good job at
managing stress and managing my anger
which in the past i haven't been as
successful with
i mean that's hard we all struggle with
that i think um
yeah it gets down like i've gotten
physically violent not at anyone but the
wall
and myself yeah um
exactly uh i was making a joke
it gets but i could do a deep dive here
is it normally stress from work that
brings that on or it's everything
like my brain is wired in a way that i'm
looking at things so
specific and detailed that like it
like occasionally you'll for example you
say
something that i i can't 100 agree
and therefore i just won't agree at all
like because i know that 20 percent of
that is slightly ina
inter uh incorrect but i don't want
to get in a deep dive and explain why
that 20 is incorrect
no it's like that that classic uh keanu
reeves moment where he's like sometimes
i just don't care
one plus three equals five sure man you
do you
good for you i'm i'm working on that uh
i haven't
hit any walls lately or myself which is
great but
uh i was able to like
stop breathe and
just go from broad stroke conversation
to
small micro conversations today and then
back out
and just walk away eat continue the
conversation a little bit further
it's really hard this is really i've had
anger issues
since forever um
so that that's something i've been
practicing and learning because i
remember in
2019 winter uh about to lose my
my home and everything just ran out of
money
not enough in too much out
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i got the worst anxiety attack
possible i fell on the floor like
seizuring and i could not stop i tried
so hard i couldn't catch my breath or
anything alicia
nearly called 9-1-1 um
it was really bad in it um
and since then i haven't stopped working
fear's a good motivator um carmichael i
think he misunderstood the question
so this is supposed to be a happy tale
it's the unknown
no i got you i was being facetious but
yeah
thankfully unknown january
just because of
the slo-mo paint drop idea
we what to film a paint drop drawing in
slow motion
and richard ryan came over and stuff
yeah
and because i mentioned to him yeah i'm
cause he's bring up some conversations i
brought up like yeah i'm going to be
leaving corridor soon
and freelancing stuff solely because of
that day
did he give me a call interesting okay
and then he sent he was like are you
still freelancing i was like yeah
i'm i'm there with like running out of
food my
my my family kind of pitched in for that
december rent january was
up in the air like i could have been out
of la by february
wow um and i was like yeah i'm totally
i'm freelancing yeah yeah
and i get a call from logan
uh talked to logan he's like uh can you
come out to vegas
it's like i could and then he's like
we'll cover
travel we'll feed you it's like great
great yeah i'll be there
um he's like this is our budget i don't
want to really go too high and i was
like i quickly did
two plus e two plus three equals six and
i was like good enough
and i i was like i'll see you in vegas
and got a job got a job
uh not really a job we got a free
landscape i got a freelance gig
that i just keep getting i keep coming
back to
i really like working for the black
rifle guys um evan's always a hoot
to film
i love it i love it
wait was that after was that after me
and jan brought the one wheel to texas
and then i didn't ride our one wheels
yes
that's how it works that's how it works
no one ever just goes and gets a one
wheel
arbitrarily and rarely do they get it
because they saw someone else riding
it's usually because they got on it and
actually tried it out
and he was trying to be one by the way
too evan was on our v1 yeah he cut you
off we went on the table
so it was i learned a lot about
youtube in a way that
i i don't think i would have ever
learned here
um do you mean like making making
content for youtube or just like
yeah so when uh starting fables right
i learned such a great deal about the
meta
expectation or the meta perspective of
the audience
when looking at content so right when
fables launched
like a lot of people came thinking it
would be node
um like this isn't node i was like yeah
i'm a dude in my living room
borrowing every piece of gear
and one of my cameras died before we
started rolling so there's no camera
for the battle cam oh no yeah no [ __ ]
this is
node um that sounds actually a lot like
node
i mean
yeah and then also my computer wasn't
strong enough to edit
any of the footage i don't know so i was
like i'll just make it look
picture-in-picture
and then walk away i'll be done because
i i can't
i'm i'm editing at five frames a second
i can't review a cut that way
also you talking about uh content uh
totally reminded me that we we didn't
talk about my episode of functional
filmmaking
no we'll leave it as a surprise okay
well i mean i i wanted to address it a
little bit because it's like we'll come
back to it then i set out because it's a
timeline thing
time line time does not go in lines
carmichael
when your editing goes in circles and
that is why clocks are around
that's not for the military observation
i can't take credit that's a quote um
don't do other people's jokes run
yeah but but like i guess what i'm
saying is like i sat down to write my
functional filmmaking episode as a way
to like describe
how i make these science videos like and
i ended up
kind of making more of a video talking
about how to make
good videos like good ideas what makes a
good idea
you really approached it you know by the
final product
what came out of it was
really solid advice for anyone who makes
you
or tries to make youtube content yeah um
uh it was specific enough that it fell
into your lap for your science videos
but it was broad enough that it kind of
lands on any genre on the internet
which is kind of what i ended up cause i
was like man no one's making like not
enough not that the audience
that makes educational entertainment
is incredibly small and i'm making
something for
them yeah no it's like okay i'm gonna
make something for
anyone who wants to make videos uh using
my science videos as like a basis of it
but it ended up kind of being more about
just how to make a good video i love it
at a certain point you're like all right
once you
know what camera you are you can watch
nico's video uh once you're in the
editing phase you can watch sam's
episode
once you're doing vfx you can oh yeah
that's right dude
you feel like you're really in the
groove and i'm like and uh yeah from now
on you're kind of on your own
you know edit upload good luck
go right i'm like it kind of feels a
little abrupt of an ending you're like
oh but i wanted to hear more
it's like well i didn't season two
didn't want to talk about more um
i talked about what i wanted to talk
about no but there's a big thing
like a lot of your advice is super solid
like
ally watches it and she goes wren's
episode's the best
i was like great
[Laughter]
too bad we didn't get jake in there that
might have threw off the skew
i would have thrown everything off well
i i think the idea behind that statement
is just that
uh mine's very generalized like clinton
is incredibly specific
yeah uh even nico's and uh sam's to a
certain degree are kind of specific
but that's the idea behind the matter
they are specific yeah
yeah there's even a specific video yeah
i feel like it's kind of general i feel
like what i wanted was to get more
specific
and i feel like my biggest worry about
when i first see this cut is that it's
going to be too general but maybe that's
what people want i don't know
i don't know yours is the episode i'm
looking forward to seeing the most
really
yes no pressure because it's advice on
how to make youtube videos essentially
it's like
honestly that's what your episode became
yeah yeah so maybe yeah it's like the
double feature
yeah don't make a youtube video because
yours is more about how to tell a story
and mine's more about
uh how to come up with a good idea
that'll sell gosh well myself i mean
like click so you know like get the
click
like our videos kind of like our uh the
antithesis of each other then because
mine's like make a story out of anything
yeah yeah
okay you don't even touch markets you
don't talk to marketing you're like no
don't do that you're gonna know that i'm
saying it's like
part of my episode is like is very much
so talking about like you have to think
about ideas
from the standpoint of a title and a
thumbnail like you can come up with a
cool idea
and it's like all right cool how do you
sell this idea what's the elevator pitch
version of this idea and it's like uh i
don't know but then
and that's where most videos on youtube
kind of suffer the content might be
great but the title
and thumbnail don't get you to click it
doesn't mean anything it's the same
thing as
saying like there's a lot of talented
people out there but they just don't
know how to like they're not
yeah they're not in the spotlight and
that's something that like we all
struggle with
every single time we make a video it's
the hardest challenge of any videos
coming up with the right
marketing oh my gosh yeah it is
difficult but another
but the the counter the counter to that
is
the fact like once you take on the task
of focusing on thumbnail and title
first before the video you no longer can
just shoot freely you know
you're like there's a gate now and
depending on the production
depending on the budget the cost the
needs
there's give and take it is it
definitely changes the vibe and like
the i guess fluidity of the shoot but
sometimes that's nice and i think
i go into that in the episode it's like
sometimes you have too much footage
and you wish that hey i wish i'd been a
little bit more pointed with what i'm
shooting yeah
yeah the whole idea behind like kind of
thinking of an idea from a title and
thumbnail standpoint is it gives you
like a goal post right it gives you a
direction
to try to aim towards and also you still
want to try to capture
all the quirky stuff you can and like
you know get everything that you think
would be good and sometimes something
happens spur of the moment that like
this is
grade a gold yeah you know capture this
is definitely going in the video
it didn't we didn't have randy and threw
a chair across the room make that the
thumbnail now
but i mean yeah but yeah that that
that's europe we
literally didn't spoil a single thing
great
um but back to my story
yes sorry speaking of what content to
make on youtube
so the meta the biggest thing i learned
from when fables and expectations
happened
is we pushed too hard on my goodbye
oh interesting so you didn't feel like
you had a payoff for it maybe
they didn't oh the audience didn't feel
like they had a page do you have videos
uploaded when we did the push i feel
like you had your first one i had promos
of introducing
okay uh my friends that were going to be
on the channel
and the first video drops it still gets
great views because it's still tethered
to that
and it gets pushes i still get people
come over to the channel on the discord
like
i just watched your goodbye video it's
like great um welcome
welcome two years later uh you have a
binge worth
of content now yeah and it's worth
one binge and the interesting thing was
on the metal level
so this comes from the idea of you go to
watch
a superhero movie right you know it's
all going to be fine the world's not
actually in danger because
they just announced three more vid
movies yeah that was my whole thing with
freaking infinity war i'm like
we haven't i don't feel any sense of
like suspense over this
yeah they come back they're going to
come back so i've been watching any
marvel movie
sorry yeah at the end of infinity war
literally half of the population of the
entire universe dies and i don't regret
it
so then at the end of the next movie
they all come back so spoilers the
uh that's on the audience level
uh a meta perspective right
another version of that is
when you watch a dnd show you're going
to
instantly compare it subconsciously to
any other dnd content you've watched
you're going to say because your brain
wants to know is this good or not that's
why
when we look at views the number of
views high number views
means good right so when you start
watching dnd content and if it's
not as well produced on the final
product
as another one that you've seen it's not
good
um even if the content might still be
good
even if the content's still good so you
face that challenge
because like a big thing is with the
corridor audience that came over
they're expecting node right and then
the further i get into the dnd and
actual play community
which is beautiful community but they
are also
comparing it to critical role dimension
20.
they're all dm layer
so many of them it just it's comparing
because you want to know
am i watching something that's worth
continuing
as soon as possible yeah um
yeah it's just interesting like getting
into the mind of the audience that's why
like when i was editing the vlogs
i didn't care the thumb and title as
much i cared about
the flow from click to click right
like moment you click how are you
experiencing this video
yeah until the moment you get out i mean
which is still king i we
with for all of our talk about like
thumbnail and title content is still the
king
aspect here it's like you know
you can have a fantastic thumbnail in
title but if the content itself if the
video itself still sucks then it's like
well you just
you suck yeah but like go back to what
you said about like
what do you mean by uh it
pushed too hard like that your goodbye
video pushed too hard like i don't
understand what you mean by that
uh i got a lot of responses
saying oh we expected better from you um
like the okay mike like the set
expectations weren't
correct yeah it was like oh my god he's
leaving he's gonna make something great
because he made something great the
vlogs
and it's like the vlogs were scrappy i
purposely made them
scrappy because i didn't have the time
to make them great
and i knew that the library itself would
be great
instead of individual videos and i still
and i still believe that philosophy
because
we're a culture that wants to watch long
content
whether we're binging on netflix one
whole season or we're watching
one week at a time on mandalorian right
um so so i know that the library of
something is going to be greater than
the individual
did you see a clint's going away with
video uh i
would have just dropped on sunday i did
two days ago i didn't watch it
uh yeah okay yeah
i mean you know i think a lot of that
video was modeled after your video
yeah a little bit a little bit yeah
clint asked a few questions ahead of
time
about that and how my video was made and
how i felt
when making those videos so we had some
heart to heart about that stuff
oh um my biggest advice was literally
set the right expectation don't push too
hard because
if you if you set an expectation the
audience goes over
expecting not just like this creator who
made this thing that i'm
emotionally attached to but the next
thing i have
is node d and d to compare it to
then if it's not that emotionally
and spectacle-wise or not even better
than that
then you should ask for your job back
carmichael that that's a that's a weekly
message i get on instagram you should
ask for your job back
carmichael that's rough man that's not
easy to get a message
i'm good okay i'm good right where i'm
at
we'll see we'll see how the summer goes
back to us i'm back just when i think
he's out
we pull him back in i i'm not going to
pull a mister in this decade i don't
know if i'm going to pull off
mr rogers are not they'll be they'll be
creepy i'm just going to say that from
now on
completely on rogers goes off the air
for three years to do
his own thing and then comes back
changes everything
do you think that like the well imagine
it's not a fun feeling
getting all those messages saying go
back to your old job go back to your old
job it's very self-serving messages too
i liked your content you're not feeding
me the content i like
yeah you should change your life you
should change your life for me
i expect i expected better from you yeah
i'm like jesus
dude that's what my wife told me in the
electric bike video i thought that's
what she said to you on
your wedding night oh
wait that's not a good thing why am i
raising my eyebrows for that
no but like there are also other people
like my patrons
uh people who are on my discord that
know that what i'm trying to do is
longevity and it's also just like covid
hit like
right when we were getting our motion
going oh yeah and i was like well i'm
gonna have to figure
out how to do this from everyone's home
to keep everyone safe and
happy and uh well it's really yeah dude
i mean we're coming back real soon which
is great
and uh i'm looking forward to the first
thing i dm on that channel
hell yeah dude that's awesome man i feel
like sometimes
i'm gonna take a lot what i learned from
son of a dungeon plop it right there
nice good man i have an assistant editor
so excited that's a step
that's a step not having to edit
everything and get tired of all the
footage before you even cut it
yeah that's the worst that's literally
the reason for an assistant is like
i don't want to be tired of my video
before i start creatively thinking about
such a thing man yeah it's such a thing
jake you're gonna play some music
i have yeah i have the guitar uh
but jake how have you been like you
moved to texas
you suffered a snowstorm dude
you got you got like three more kids
coming out of your your wood beams
i thought that was i thought you're
gonna finish that sentence very
differently
you got kids coming out of the beams i'm
good man
everything's good yeah but yeah
has it been hard producing corridor from
over in texas
it's at its challenges yeah yeah
but we're making it it's working yeah
it's working
jake's like i'm gonna save all this for
the next episode
[Laughter]
hearing this stay tuned consider
subscribing to the corridor cass
carmichael if you want to come back man
we can we can continue this conversation
but i'm literally
blocks away guys i actually do kind of
want to hear how texas has been going
because
you haven't debriefed us at all like
what is it like down there
hear about that
consider subscribing yeah
yeah move that arm move it
carmichael i'm glad you're doing well
and i'm glad we get to work together
still
and uh this song's for you buddy
i'm just trying to freaking hey
hey stop that you're david carmichael
j just mute ren your name brings me joy
that's it model solo
wait what would be a good note to
resonate with you
dude no one crinkles like me
no one's wrinkled
ready i'm gonna yell in three two one